two years after the outbreak of covet 19
china is battling with its highest ever
case numbers the country's largest city
shanghai is the worst hit 26 million
people there are under strict lockdown
but as china pursues its strict zero
covet policy cracks in people's patients
are beginning to show fabian krechma
reports
for weeks the streets of shanghai have
been empty
supermarkets are shut
delivery workers that would normally be
weaving their way through the city are
nowhere to be seen
social media is full of cries for help
and complains about a lack of food
some videos show unrest in neighborhoods
where people are desperate to find food
and in one unverified video people are
even seen looting a supermarket
authorities are scrambling to deliver
supplies but there are huge problems
that's what i personally found for
delivering vegetables some are getting
their food early some are getting it
late it has a big impact on people's
lives qin yin lei is a tomato farmer who
works on the outskirts of the city
he's doing his part to try and help he's
moved out of his home and into a dorm at
the industrial greenhouses where his
company grows tomatoes
this is a video he shot on his phone of
the room he's staying in
we're under staffed at the moment and
need to ensure we keep up production so
we start work early and work overtime
for about two hours a day but reports
say the biggest hurdle in the delivery
of goods is at the last mile many
delivery workers and other supply
personnel remain under lockdown
themselves the challenge is in getting
food from markets and warehouses to
people's homes the local government is
now trying to mobilize delivery workers
to get back to work as long as there
aren't any positive cases within their
residential compounds
the bottlenecks could pose a serious
problem to the government frank zai is
ceo and founder of china crossroads and
a risk specialist
he's a resident of shanghai and has been
under locked on himself for over a week
when you induce food insecurity
to a country whose purpose is to
modernize and make people's lives better
i think it adds a certain twist that
that you know
people here and the leadership here are
are not
are not so comfortable with for the past
two years china has touted its approach
towards containing the virus and pointed
towards its rampant spread in the west
as a marker of its superiority this
could break the narrative that uh
china's system is better at doing this
especially if it really explodes in the
next few weeks
so we could be at quite an inflection
point uh in how kobut evolves and and
how the world comes to see china's
performance on kobit but how its own
people see it is what matters the most
and authorities will need to get a
handle on the situation quickly to
prevent people's frustration from
spiraling any further
well earlier i spoke to fabian ketchumer
who filed that report
yeah so basically the city has been
separated into three different
categories um if you live in a
residential compound meaning your
apartment complex your neighborhood
community where there were um cases
detected within the last week that means
you cannot um even leave your flat if
you um live in a compound where there
were no cases detected in the last week
but within the last
two weeks so basically the last uh
14 days and you're allowed to leave your
flat but um can only go within your
gated community you're not allowed to go
to the street and only for those people
who live in a neighborhood community
where there were no cases for the last
two weeks um they are allowed to go to
the street now but only in a confined
area and there's really not much to do
so i mean public transportation is
basically shut all the public facilities
are shut so i mean it is an easing but a
very cautious one and as soon as there's
one only one um single case within your
whole neighborhood the um uh community
shuts down again so it's really
precarious right so you can travel to
shanghai we're hearing from these
restrictions that you've just mentioned
um what's your sense of how serious the
situation is there in shanghai
well it's an emergency situation which
slightly gets better by time but
basically you can see how serious the
situation is by the situation of the uh
by the decision of the u.s consulate in
shanghai today they basically um force
their non-essential staff to fly out um
because they cannot guarantee their
safety and when i talk to residents both
locals and also expats their concerns
are really um quite existential they
fear that the food supply will not be
enough they fear that
they
get separated from their children if the
the children test positive um they also
in general are not so much afraid of the
virus but more afraid of um getting
dragged into the isolation centers
because the hygienic conditions they are
really um
quite devastating and you basically
are locked there with
several thousands of people and it's
really not a pleasant experience so i
think um
it's getting better with time and we saw
the
recent easing but um it's yeah i mean
it's a really tense situation fabian are
there any signs that the government is
perhaps rethinking how it deals with the
virus
so far not really i mean the economic
costs are really going high i mean we
know that
the global supply chains they are really
stressed right now and the service
sector is going down the manufacturing
sector i mean basically 90 percent of
the big cities here in china have been
to some degree affected by lockdowns in
the last um uh two months but um i think
the government is committed also because
of their own propaganda they stated that
um we can manage zero covert uh we are
the only country that can contain the
virus and uh that is a proof of our
superiority and now to change that
course it is really very difficult also
to justify uh towards their own
population
that was fabian kretschmer in beijing